thank you for inviting me today i will
discuss
the advantages and challenges of broad
molecular profiling
this is my disclosure as you can see i
have
received a speaker on area and also
non-financial support from term official
scientific which is
the provider of the oncoming
comprehensive
plus assay which i will discuss
during my talk
so i would like to start uh the
discussion about
uh genomic profiling in general and why
it is
so relevant nowadays as we know from
clinical practice and if
as you see here from this slide in
also from clinical trials and their
current design
we went from enrolling patient
exclusively based on
the tumor type to having a
nice selection of biomarker defined
patient populations
either within specific tumor types so
in umbrella tires as you can see here
in the middle section of this figure
for example for her2 amplifications as a
biomarker we have trastutimab as a drug
for alf translocations in specifically
in lung cancer we have cryptotiny as a
drug
and uh for b rap mutations uh in
melanoma we have the murafinib as a drug
but we also um very importantly um
can select collect just
based on molecular abnormality
and we can have this agnostic
histology agnostic approval of drugs
nowadays which
happened as in the last example
for microsoft lighting stable
cancers so in general sonic tumors that
are mismatch deficient mismatch repair
deficient
and that can uh that that can receive
temporary zoom up so immune checkpoint
inhibitors
um however yeah i just spoke about
four of such molecular biomarkers
why do we need comprehensive genomic
profiling
the number of of these biomarkers is
increasing every year
here you can see a picture showing
just a few representative biomarkers to
the situation
uh that evolved in the last 20 years and
you can see that for example in the last
six years
we have more than one biomarker-based
therapy that was approved or that was uh
that became
relevant in the clinical field and
of course this is a great news for
for patient management
however it also it is also required
uh that that clinicians
perform broad molecular testing uh to be
able to
assess all these different biomarkers
and now um i would like to again
stress this point so um the
so-called actionable genes so genes that
are directly associated with treatment
and for which
there is a drug that is fda approved are
not so many
during my talk i will talk about the
next generation sequencing
assays and here you can see there are
only 55 genes
that are therapy approved for all cancer
types and 55 target genes can be easily
covered by
small next generation sequencing assays
so why do we need comprehensive genomic
profiling so broader
next generation sequencing here you can
see that the picture is different if we
look at genes that are installed
associated
with the clinical trial there is this
magic number which is uh close to 500
genes
that are associated with other therapy
options
and of course you can imagine that this
information is very valuable
when there was no finding
of molecular operation in the previously
mentioned
55 or so genes
and in advanced cancer settings
moving to clinical research what are the
options for comprehensive
genomic profiling so the words we can go
is whole genome sequencing
which however is time consuming
from the analysis point of view and also
very expensive
however it allows to to sequence
the whole tumor genome
if we want to go a little bit less broad
we can sequence only the coding part
of the tumor genome uh with the
so-called whole axon sequencing
um which only sequences exon
and this is of course a bit less
expensive and time-consuming but still
still on the broader or larger
size pipes and then we have clinical
exome sequencing which instead is
consistent sequencing
only clinically relevant or let's say
cancer related
actions however here we are still
we are still talking about about
expensive methods that also required
really time consuming analysis
what has come up in the last two three
years
is actually a targeted sequential
sequencing approaches which uh
anyway are broad enough to allow
comprehensive genomic profiling
and here you can see uh two examples on
the right side of my slide
um we have the two side 500 oncology
assay from illumina
and we have the uncommand comprehensive
assay plus from thermo fischer
scientific
i will now share with you our results
obtained using the uncommand
comprehensive assay plus
and here is an overview of this assay it
it includes 500 genes that can be
assayed
from both dna and rna levels
and so we can we can inspect single
nucleotide variants index as well as
copy number alterations
from the dna point of view and then we
can have uh
analysis of fusion and slice variants
from the rna side
this assay also allows to assess immune
oncology research targets
as are the famous demonstrational burden
or
microsatellite instability and very
importantly
because it is for oncology research
it is comparable compatible with
ffp tissue and it
only requires 20 nanograms of input
material and we know that nowadays
cancer specimens biopsies become smaller
and smaller so this is a very important
point
it is also based on the traditional
oncoming workflow
thus if this workflow is already
available
in the laboratory it is easy to
implement it
i also would like to stress that among
these immuno ecology research targets
there are also
a nice collection of genes that are
that are actually that have actually
been associated in clinical research
with response or resistance the
resistance to
for example immune checkpoint inhibitors
here you see
at the bottom of this list stick 11 and
keep one
which uh together with keras alterations
have been associated
uh with resistance to immune checkpoint
inhibitors
and on the top of the list you also see
several genes
that are associated with antigen
presentation and also here
again mutations loss of functional
mutations
for example in beta2 microglobulin has
been associated with
resistance from to immunotherapy
here i want to show you our results
we have used uncombined compressive
assay plus to profile
25 cancer samples uh from which
we had that were previously
characterized in our lab
and here you can see the results
obtained
on six of uh of these samples four
non-smoother lung cancers and two
uh colorectal cancer samples uh that
were provided with one of the so-called
[Music]
small or um yes i would say the smaller
uh
targeted ngs spanish the oncomites
tumor dna which is also ivd labeled
and you can see here that we found 13
mutations
across these six samples and some of
which
very clinically relevant as you can see
at the bottom of my site we found
limitations for only one
sample in egfr um
exo19 division t790m and 797
and these mutations really are crucial
for um
or are associated with resistance
and response from um a igfr
thousand kinase inhibitors and you can
see that the oncoming comprehensive
assay plus performed well
as our smaller panel so there is 100
sensitivity and positive predictive
value so all mutations were detected
uh by uh by the assay
if we go a little bit broader instead so
we have analyzed
17 non-muscle and cancer samples with
the oncoming tumor mutational load which
is
actually used for tumor mutational
burden estimation and we have validated
it in our unit for this purpose
um as well as for variant calling
if samples are sequenced at an
appropriate depth
and here you can see um we have uh
found 121 mutation across the 17 samples
and again also here sensitivity of the
uncommon comprehensive assay was 99
and also positive predictive value was
very high
to continue talking about the tumor
mutational burden
we analyzed these 17 non-smothelan
cancer samples in a retrospective
clinical research study and we had
information
about about response status
from immune checkpoint inhibitors and
also pdl one status
assessed by munisto chemistry for these
temples
and you can see this information
summarized here
in the plot that is in the middle of the
slide
so this is an onco print and each column
represents
one sample on top you can see the green
samples
showed durable clinical benefit which
corresponds to progression-free survival
longer than six months and the gray
samples
on the right side of the plot are
instead
no durable clinical benefit observed
um you can also see the human
compressive assay plus
allows to assess the microsatellite
instability status however these were
all lung cancer samples so
they all were a microsoft light stable
we had as i said pdl1 status information
and you can see here the tps score
represented by purple
gradient color and you can see two
mutational burden tmb as assessed by the
uncommand compressive assay plus
so very interestingly you can see
the darkest shade of orange represents
tmb high patients
and you can see that two patients out of
eight due to two samples out of eight
durable clinical benefit
um were actually tmb
law however all other samples at tmb
high and for the no responders instead
also here we have two samples that were
t and b high
but showed no response
if we go and look at the mutational
status of these patients we also can see
some interesting features
so as as i discussed before
stick stick 11 and keep one
mutations especially in association with
chaos
have been linked to um two resistance
from immune checkpoint inhibitors and
indeed we
did find them only in our no durable
benefit
cohort um talking about tmb i also
want to share with you a correlation
that we have done with an orthogonal
path for tmb
estimation here you can see actually tmb
is assessed by
foundation medicine and this test
uh actually or this correlation uh
is was done with only six samples
however the results are
i would say pretty good and this is
important because harmonization of
tmb estimation between different assays
is critical and it's been very discussed
recently and
we also characterized using the oncoming
comprehensive assay plus
eight colorectal cancer samples that
were previously tested with the testo
panel
for microsoft light instability and they
also were tested by
via immunist chemistry for mismatch
repair
protein loss and here you can see
a representative immunist chemistry of
the four proteins are usually tested
and of which loss indicates
a mismatch repair deficiency
and you can see here that in the middle
plot
again each column representing one
different sample
we had three samples in orange that
showed loss of expression uh in one of
the mismatch repair proteins
and very nicely we could recapitulate
that loss uh by finding truncating
mutation
in the corresponding protein using the
oncoming comprehensive assay plus
as i said before the assay allows to
estimate microcephalitis stability by
giving a microsatellite
instability score and you can see here
that the micro satellite infestability
score
correlated quite well with the number of
satellite markers that were instable
according to the beta panel we also had
tmb estimation i would say tmb also
coral light
correlates quite well with the micro
satellite
score and with the tester panel number
of markers in stable
however not in all cases and
if we look at the nice collection of
mutations that we have detected in the
samples
you can also see that very importantly
there are two two samples that show
truncating mutation in beta2
microglobulin
and this mutation would speak for a
resistance
from immune checkpoint inhibitors
however the samples are
also msi high
actually samples which would instead uh
would instead predict uh response from
immune checkpoint inhibitors therefore
these findings have to be
interpreted with caution
i would also like to give you an outlook
on our future plans
we also want to validate another
another feature of the uncommand
compressive assay plus
us we are particularly interested in
this feature
and it is about copy number alterations
um so ngs is routinely used
for mutations of variant
detection in in in cancer specimens
however copy number variation
through ngs is not yet been established
and the current methods are
mostly arrays so for example snip arrays
or dna methylation arrays
most recently and
however as you can see the uncommand
compressive assay plus has an impressive
collection of genes
and the amplicon design allows actually
to
detect for specific cnb gains and losses
therefore we want to test this feature
and we plan to include
40 cancer samples we with non-clinically
relevant copy number variations
and as orthogonal methods to validate we
plan to use
the illumina infinium dna methylum array
as well as the
oncospa oncoscan cmd plus kit
i also want to focus on one more feature
of the panel
and this is regards the
analysis of the data so analysis
of comprehensive genomic profiling data
can be
very cumbersome and uh instead this
assay offers an integrated solution to
india
reporter software and um i think
this is a very big advantage uh because
it is
automatable but is also a customized
customizable option and you can see here
actually that
the interface is very um very intuitive
and user friendly
so we can have immediate information
about
two mutational burden and msi score as
well as the mutations that are detected
and there is also the possibility of
setting
customized filter chains to just
see mutations that pass specific
qc parameters
so to conclude i would like to briefly
discuss the advantages and the
challenges of comprehensive genomic
profiling
between the advantages we can have a
higher probability of
identifying relevant biomarkers by doing
broader
genomic analysis however there is also
higher probability of detecting variant
of a non-significant as well as therapy
non-relevant information
the biomatic bioinformatics workflow is
evolving
to simplify the analysis however as i
just said the analysis of
broad genomic profiling results can be
cumbersome and much longer than for
targeted and smaller next generation
sequencing
assays it is a one-stop-shop
option so we can see genomic alterations
as well as tnb and nfi status
however this might not be required in
all situations
so it is important still to pay
attention to
the clinical context and
in conclusion i also would like to say
that this assay
is so broad that it can be used
independently from the cancer type so
it it fits different cancer types so it
can be used as a standardized
laboratory procedure however of course
it requires
higher number of sequencing leads
therefore higher price and most of
these assays also require higher input
dna however this is like
likely not the case for the oncoming
comprehensive essay plot
so finally i would say that
comprehensive genomic profiling in
general
will prove very important in the context
of
immunotherapy um you can see here that
there are
really several biomarkers that are being
studied and some of them are already
being used in the clinics to
to address the possibility the
probability of
response from immunotherapy
and i believe that comprehensive genomic
profiling will support
will support this by allowing to account
for
several biomarkers and their interaction
and
potentially allowing to better precision
in
patient stratification
with this i would like to thank you for
your attention and i also would like to
thank
the molecular assay development unit of
the institute of pathology
of basel as well as our
our clinicians that supported these
studies
and thermo facial scientific thank you
very much